Hi hi how are you you have questions yes I I
add a lot of questions I'm sure you had a lot
of questions but rest assured we're going
to answer them right now like for example
how is Wolverine alive yeah after Logan Logan
uh takes place in 2029 totally separate thing
Logan died in Logan not touching that
what actually happens in our film is
thank you Kevin feige Love You
Kevin feige thank you MCU wake me up
welcome back everyone it's Charlie Ryan Reynolds
dropped a new Deadpool 3 teaser with Wolverine and
they talked a little bit more about the actual
plot how it fits into the cannon so we'll break
it all down of course I'll be doing a bunch of
videos for the movie as we get more footage and
learn more about the actual plot so if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos but the big deal on this teaser video is
that they just confirmed that they're not going
to retcon the events of the Logan movie like the
events of the movie will take place before the
events of the Logan movie that takes place in the
year 2029 in the fox Marvel universe so they can
literally do anything that they want during the
events of this movie without affecting the Canon
of Logan there's a whole section of the video
where they try to spoil the plot and tell you
what's actually happening but they play the George
Michael song so you can't hear what they're saying
this is actually a lip reading of what they're
actually saying get out yes and he's like and
I'm just like what the and I justand then um and
I'm chasing them all over the place and we're
going through and we're gonna have this place and
just huge huge yeah and I've got the swords wow
that's it but I'm fine I'm totally laughing
and I'm alive too but really get to see this
because we're in our Prime is true the
prime and what a way to make it up to you
so the joke there is they're not really saying
anything like it's just a lot of gibberish about
explosions and them fighting each other because
at the end of the first teaser when they show
that Deadpool logo you see Wolverine's claws
literally claw right through it as if he's in
the middle of a fight with Deadpool like Deadpool
versus Wolverine that was one of my theories when
they first released this like oh it'll start
the movie and it'll be like Deadpool versus
Wolverine but eventually they will work together
and it'll be more of a team up by the end of the
film because during the lip reading portion you
see Ryan Reynolds slicing Hugh Jackman up with his
katanas B and Arthur because Golden Girls and Hugh
Jackman is pretending to stab him in the head with
his claws and if it's been a while since you've
seen Deadpool or any of the Wolverine movies the
big joke here is that they both have powers of
almost instant regeneration I think in the comics
technically Deadpool's regeneration is supposed
to be a little bit more powerful than Wolverines
just like a little bit quicker but I think part
of the joke of the movie is going to be it'll be
pretty even like they will both slice the hell out
of each other and then instantly almost heal it so
just keep going at each other almost indefinitely
until they figure out that they need to work
together like they could literally spend all day
slicing their body parts off and they would just
heal them almost instantly think about how long
it would take a fight like that to play out if you
have two characters who almost never get tired but
the other really interesting Easter egg especially
in that first trailer is when Ryan Reynolds is
talking about figuring out the plot of the movie
he talks about multiple versions of Deadpool like
he says how each Dead Pool should feel different
his first appearance in the MCU obviously needs to
feel special we need to stay true to the character
find new depth and motivation meaning every
Deadpool needs to stand out and stand apart
it's been an incredible challenge that has forced
me to reach down deep inside it does sound like a
very tongue-in-cheek type of teaser because in
the Logan movie they have the whole idea of the
Wolverine clones that were being made of him
so there were a bunch of versions of Wolverine
including x-23 who is another female clone of
Wolverine but in the MCU movies they've been
doing variants because of the Multiverse Arc and
Kevin feige and the Marvel people have said that
Deadpool 3 will be in the MCU even though they're
going to treat it like its own thing like it'll
be rated R so it won't be in the same tone as
a lot of the other Marvel movies it'll be in
the tone of a typical Deadpool movie like you
would expect they'll just be leaning on more
of the overarching MCU plot MCU tropes and MCU
characters so the early Theory just thinking
about this overarching Marvel phase 4 Multiverse
plot is that Deadpool 3 will involve variants of
Deadpool that they do wind up trying to Perma kill
like the main Deadpool in the main Wolverine will
try to eventually kill that Deadpool and they
might wind up doing a version of Deadpool kills
the Marvel Universe but they do it as a version of
Deadpool kills the fox Marvel Universe with a bit
of a tongue-in-cheek type of joke like we're
moving into the MCU now and we're destroying
whole universes his first appearance in the
MCU obviously needs to feel special because if
you have this whole idea of incursions that are
happening especially like in the doctor strange
2 post-credits scene what do you expect Deadpool
to do something as crazy as destroying an entire
universe and not totally meaning to like whoops
okay I guess we should just go to this other
Universe now and that other Universe just happens
to be the MCU you also have the idea that they're
going to want to use him in other MCU movies
like there's Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty Avengers
6 Secret Wars he's probably definitely going
to be in secret Wars I don't know what their
Cameo plans for for other movies beyond that just
Avengers movies are pretty safe bet for him I've
already addressed them bringing back Hugh Jackman
Wolverine the whole idea is they might wind up
recasting a version eventually in the future like
they might actually transition to a new version
without killing him off because they don't want to
obviously retcon the events of the Logan movie and
I don't think it's going to be a variance of the
character I think it'll be like the main Wolverine
that we've been watching this whole time in the
main dead pool that we've been watching this
whole time and because it is kind of complicated
the way they explain like how they're connecting
all the fox stuff to the MCU stuff we have seen a
variant of Patrick Stewart's Professor X but it's
not like the main Fox Marvel version it was meant
to be like a completely different version it was
a little bit closer to the version that we saw
during X-Men the Animated Series I think part of
the beauty of Deadpool movies is that you can do
the original versions of those characters and you
can do all this Multiverse stuff the incursion
stuff and Deadpool just has to call it out he
can hang a light on it and how complicated it
is and how none of it makes sense but I think
the actual main plot of the movie will be a little
bit simpler more in the tone of the first Deadpool
movie I think they kind of got off the rails
with the second Deadpool movie and all that X4
stuff like the main plot of Deadpool 3 will be
relatively simple and it'll be like a slightly
upgraded version of the Deadpool Wolverine Road
Trip plot that Ryan Reynolds said that they had
planned to do for Deadpool 3 until the big fox
Disney buyout like I think they literally just
went back to the original plot of what that movie
would have been and just upgraded a little bit
and Incorporated it into this big Marvel phase 4
Multiverse plot in order to keep the plot of the
Logan movie into hack remember that takes place in
2029 there's still several years worth of plot and
crossovers that he can do before they have to get
a version of that original Hugh Jackman Wolverine
back to the fox Marvel Universe for the events of
that movie but I think that they're going to do a
version of Deadpool kills the fox Marvel Universe
they just have a couple of jokes about that like
he wouldn't completely destroy the entire universe
because then they wouldn't be able to send Hugh
Jackman Wolverine back to that Universe for the
events of the Logan movie there's also ways that
you can explain it if you've read the comic book
Secret Wars ARC the more recent one read Richards
basically uses Franklin Richards to repopulate the
entire Multiverse like bring everything back so to
speak so there's a lot of easy ways that you can
bring Hugh Jackman into all these Marvel movies
and do more crossovers even do a version of him
in secret Wars and then have the characters fix
the Multiverse at the end of that storyline and
then eventually he goes back to the fox Marvel
Universe for the events of Logan a lot of people
also asking if the house that they're in is the
same house from the Logan movie it doesn't look
exactly the same but what they might be doing
is just having a joke about being in a similar
version Look this looks kind to like the version
of the house from Logan we also found out the
specific comic book that he's reading on the
toilet in the Deadpool costume he's reading a
copy of Wolverine Vol 7 number 21 and I don't
think the story of that comic book has anything
to do with the plot of the Deadpool 3 specifically
I think the reason to use it in the teaser video
is probably just because as of the day he posted
the video it's the most recent Deadpool Wolverine
crossover in the comics like he's trying to figure
out the plot of the movie so he's reading a lot
of Deadpool Wolverine crossover stories when you
rewatch The First Deadpool movie The funny thing
you might recognize too is the idea that he uses
the Hugh Jackman face meaning that Hugh Jackman
the actor is Canon to the fox Marvel Universe
and Wolverine is like a completely separate entity
so we'll see if they make any references or jokes
about that like with him asking Wolverine if he's
ever met Hugh Jackman or just Clowning on the Hugh
Jackman actor while Wolverine is standing next
to him it's like the Star Wars problem in the
MCU that a lot of people recognize when Spider-Man
debuted in Captain America's Civil War and started
referencing all those Star Wars moments because
then Star Wars became Canon to the MCU meaning
the prequels are Canon to the MCU and Nick Fury
looks remarkably similar to the actor Samuel L
Jackson who played Mace Windu so like you have
Nick Fury but you also have the actor Samuel L
Jackson who's also Canon to the MCU that also
feels like a very Deadpool kind of meta joke
also the really cool thing now too is Elizabeth
Olsen was talking about coming back as Scarlet
Witch and because Hugh Jackman Wolverine X-Men
stuff now happening inside the MCU she said that
she wanted to do a big Crossover with them and
Kevin foggy also confirmed we haven't seen the
last of Scarlet Witch so I think we all believe
that she would come back now they can actually
do a Scarlet Witch X-Men crossover story for
real but if we get any more Easter eggs or we
find out anything more about the plot of course
I'll do videos about it everyone just posts all
your theories in the comments below like what
do you want them to do for the actual plot of
the movie if it's going to be connected to the
MCU it doesn't have to all take place in the MCU
it's just at some point during the film they both
have to get into the MCU everyone click here for
that other Deadpool 3 Wolverine rain trailer video
and click here for my house in the Dragon episode
7 video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!